my brother's six years older so we're
raised together
he's slowly gaining weight his wife
adopts our diet comes in and fast
overcomes her own health issues he's on
a vegan program 15 years later my
brother's still eating chicken and doing
stuff and getting fatter and he's got he
can't do play volleyball anymore his
legs all swollen up i you know i'm
poking him but he he won't do anything
finally he calls me from the hospital he
says alan i'm in the hospital
i had a heart attack so he said oh they
want to do a quadruple bypass and i said
well talk to your surgeon he asked the
surgeon he says
if you do a bypass won't they plug up
again
and search yeah eventually but you know
last longer than stenson he says what if
i made radical diet and lifestyle change
he said the surgeon laughed at him
he said mark you're not gonna make diet
and lifestyle changes come on
checked himself out
got on a whole plant food sos free diet
lost the 50 pounds back to playing
volleyball passed his stress test still
has his vessels